okay so the topic of this video is a
type of cell transport called active
transport now before we go into active
transport let's take a moment and
refresh the other kinds of transports
that were mentioned in previous videos
on the far left we're going to have an
example of simple diffusion in this
animation you can see the green circles
are more concentrated on top and they
are diffusing to the bottom until
there's a nice equal distribution until
there's what's called equilibrium in the
middle of the picture we have what's
called facilitated diffusion now it's
very similar to diffusion because
molecules are moving from a high
concentration you can see in the picture
on top to the bottom where they are
lowly concentrated that movement will
continue until again there's a nice
balance the difference being in
facilitated diffusion the molecules are
too large to simply squeeze through the
cell membrane so they travel through
those protein channels both of these two
examples are what we call passive
transport because the cell does not need
to expend any energy in order to move
those molecules it's a natural process
but this video is going to focus on the
far right on the far right we're going
to have what's called active transport
in a moment you're going to see the big
difference but watch this
there's a molecule flashing right here
symbolic of a molecule called ATP
adenosine triphosphate and this is an
energy molecule and with the help of
this energy molecule called ATP during
active transport molecules will be moved
from where they are lowly concentrated
to where they are highly concentrated so
it's really just the opposite of passive
transport so let's go ahead and go into
the details now so if you seen my
previous videos on passive transport we
had a kayaker that was in a river but
the kayaker was facing the direction
that the current was traveling on in
this case the kayaker is opposite of the
current so does this kayaker need to
spend his energy in order to move
of course I'm sure you would know the
answer would be yes this kayaker is
going to have to you know use the paddle
and put a lot of energy a lot of muscle
to fight the flow of the water and so
active transport is kind of like a
kayaker going upstream so with active
transport molecules move against the
normal process of diffusion molecules
are moving from a low concentration to a
high concentration
they're moving not down the
concentration gradient but they're
moving up the concentration gradient and
if you kind of imagine an analogy like
for instance moving uphill pedaling a
bicycle uphill you know that's going to
require some energy so in inactive
transport energy is required in my
animation you can see that brown circle
is trapped inside of that protein
channel that's embedded within the cell
membrane so what's going to happen is a
molecule of ATP adenosine triphosphate
is going to reconfigure and reshape that
protein channel so with the release of
energy the protein channel will change
shape that will allow that Brown circle
to pass to the other side of the cell
membrane
notice how the protein channel then went
back to its original shape and this
process would then repeat with another
input of ATP and so active transport
acts like a pump it's a way for
molecules and ions to be pumped either
into the cell or out of the cell
depending on where they're needed but if
you think about a pump any kind of pump
like a bicycle pump if you want to pump
up your bicycle tire if you want to pump
up a soccer ball you need to input some
energy in order for a pump to work and
in the world of cells energy comes in
the form of a molecule called adenosine
triphosphate ATP so here's a great
example of of a cell with a pump in this
case it's called a contractile vacuole
this is an organism by the name of
Paramecium it's very small microscopic
you need a microscope to see it it lives
in power and water and paramecia they
live in watery environment the problem
because they live in watery environments
the problem is the cell could actually
over inflate with water if too much
water enters the Paramecium by simple
diffusion the cell could burst and the
Paramecium could die so the contractile
vacuole you can see the black box
highlighting the contractile vacuole in
this picture the contractile vacuole
contracts and everytime it contracts it
will squirt out some of the excess water
that is inside of the cell prevents the
cell from bursting you know for those of
you who might be familiar with boats
boats have what's called a bilge on them
in case the boat ever springs a leak and
ocean water comes rushing into the boat
a bilge will turn on and pump out the
water to hopefully keep you afloat long
enough either to reach the shore or for
help to come and get you so this picture
by the way I took this from the Coast
Guard website and for those of you who
are into boating I hope that these are
good safety tips here for you when you
consider your bilge on your boat but
let's come back to the Paramecium here
let's zoom on in and take a look at this
process so here we have a Paramecium and
it's sitting in water and like the the
notes say water simply diffuses into the
Paramecium from a high concentration to
a low concentration you can see the
black dots are representing water
molecules and they're diffusing in the
problem is this Paramecium could
eventually burst like a balloon inflated
with too much air
this Paramecium could burst so to
prevent from bursting the Paramecium has
what's called a contractile vacuole in
the animation you can see the
contractile vacuole is pumping what what
is it pumping it's pumping out a lot of
the excess water that has simply
diffused in but this pump requires
energy
energy in the form of ATP again it's a
great example of active transport
another type another type of way that
cells can take in and move molecules is
what's called endocytosis now if you
break the word into prefix and suffix
endo simply means inside Saito refers to
the cell so the word means take inside
the cell so endocytosis is a process
where the cell will take in substances
through the cell membrane now there's
kind of two sub categories of
endocytosis and one of them is called
phagocytosis and this is when a cell
will take in and engulf and swallow up a
solid molecule solid solid particles in
the animation you see that yellow object
has been taken in taken in a little more
taken in a little more taken in a little
more and now it's fully surrounded by
the cell membrane and so perhaps this
was a bacteria that the cell swallowed
up so it'll kill it perhaps this was the
yellow object perhaps it was a food
molecule that the cell really needed on
the inside by the way my notes say that
WBC's white blood cells WBC stands for
white blood cells are a type of
phagocyte they're called phagocytes
because they swallow up bacteria and
viruses through what's called
phagocytosis the second type of
endocytosis is called pinocytosis and
the very similar in concept the
difference between Faygo and pinocytosis
is that in pinocytosis the cell will it
will engulf and take in liquid particles
but the concept is this one thing I want
to mention is that unfortunately viruses
can also enter our cells through the
process called endocytosis here we have
a cell membrane and on the outside of
cell membranes we have these little
lumps called receptors and watch what
happens in this case and this animation
of virus will match the receptor now
normally when an object matches the
receptor that object is a needed
molecule then the cell will need that
molecule on the inside but
viruses have adapted to match our
receptors and kind of fool and trick
ourselves into thinking it's a needed
molecule and needed nutrients of some
kind so in the animation the viruses
matched the receptor and the cell will
begin to swallow it up through the
process called phagocytosis and
ultimately now that the virus has been
swallowed up by phagocytosis the virus
can then release its DNA or its RNA into
the host cell and ultimately can begin
the destruction of that particular cell
when we learn about viruses later on the
school year will go into this process in
a little more detail but that's
unfortunately one way that viruses have
kind of learned to use our cells against
us the viruses have learned to use the
cell's natural process against us so the
opposite of endocytosis simply is EXO
cytosis you break the word down into
prefix and suffix excess or EXO excuse
me EXO means to give offer to release to
exit Saito Saito simply means the cell
so the word literally means exit from
the cell so in this case we're going to
show you that process it's a process
where substances and molecules are
expelled or released from a cell so
example of mouth of items that are
released from cells you can see right
here proteins and nutrients and waste so
our cell is constantly creating waste
and that we needs to be released and so
what we're going to show you in just a
moment is that a cell part by the name
on an organelle by the name of a vesicle
will carry and release objects through
the cell membrane through the plasma
membrane so here we have in my animation
a vesicle carrying about four black dots
well notice what happened is that the
vesicle has fused with the cell membrane
the cell membrane and the vesicle are
made from the same bilayer phospholipid
bilayer and so they literally just kind
of fuse in form with one another and
as the process continues the vesicle
slowly is taken into the cell membrane
and eventually the black dots are
released those objects are released from
the inside of the cell to the outside of
the cell so there you go there's a real
quick video on active transport notice
the big difference again is that it
requires the input of ATP energy if
you're in my biology class you know
pause this video try to answer these
seven questions and bring me your
answers before school or after school
one day I'd be happy to check them for
accuracy pause the video good luck